[Musique]
bonjour maurice montée oui bonjour à
vous bourgeois la population
martiniquaise et singulièrement bonjour
aux bouillonnait ce serait le nom des
habitants d'alsace au pavillon les
boulonnaises et les bouillonnait alors
meurice bonté vous êtes mère justement
de cette bonne ville d'ajouts pas
bouillon depuis 1995 vous êtes âgé de 70
ans et vous êtes également le président
sortant de l'association des maires de
la martinique
alors vous voulez donc entamé un
cinquième mandat
ainsi vous serez élu au mois de mars
prochain c'est c'est bien ça c'est un
cinquième mandat qui vous attend alors
élu depuis 1995
à 70 ans vous auriez pu peut-être vous
dire ben on arrête vous auriez pu être
là c'est finalement de cette fonction de
maire bah non
pourquoi mm non pourquoi pense que c'est
simplement moi j'ai toujours tenu à rome
et cajou pas brillant tout ce que cette
petite ville m'a donné mon éducation à
façon de vivre et puis aussi
naturellement tout ce que j'ai pu
récolter de bons sur cette petite ville
et puis bon cette petite ville n'est pas
encore terminée si vrai que bon mais
nous avons récupéré en 95
une ville pas trop brillante 1 avec
naturellement elle est pas mal de choses
à faire
aujourd'hui je crois que personne na na
se plaignent de cette petite ville
puisque bon mais nous avons mal à pas
mal de réalisation et comme nous n'avons
pas encore terminé moi j'ai décidé de
poursuivre et engrossé ou un autre
mandat ça va me faire le cinquième est
en fin de compte
de plus souvent lorsqu'on a envie de
qu'elle fait quelque chose de ce que fut
fait quelque chose
le temps ne compte pas on voit pas le
temps passer même temps passer et
plusieurs fois utilisé le terme de
petites villes c'est un terme affectueux
je pense de votre part vous désigne
ajoupa bouillon comme une petite ville
par rapport à son cachet mais son nombre
d'habitants aussi bien ses membres d'aby
c'est surtout par son nombre d'habitants
parce qu'en fin de compte il faut bien
se le dire un certain moment il faut je
vous ai parlé de mon éducation
l'essentiel pour nous de la seconde
arrive en 95 c'était remettre un peu de
l'autre dans la moralité de la mentalité
de la population refait aux familles
lorsqu'en fin de compte que je crois que
c'est ça c'était un peu perdu c'est
pourquoi je dis aujourd'hui que notre
petite famille notre petite famille une
toute petite ville la joue pas bouillon
moins de 2000 habitants
c'est une gestion je crois que ce n'est
pas trop compliqué trop difficile avec
naturellement une équipe administrative
n'est qu'une équipe technique qui qui
qui donne beaucoup satisfaction donc je
pense que moi mais tout ce que je dois
joue pas bouillon - mais je le remet
aujourd'hui sages les faits sans effort
alors votre quatrième mandat celui qui
s'achève a été marquée aussi par le fait
que vous les rappeler en tout début
d'entretien que vous avez été pendant
cette mandature président de
l'association des maires de la
martinique
ce qui est peut-être même une forme de
prouesse de performance en soi puisque
vous même vous avez rappelé à joues pas
bouillon l'une des communes les moins
habitées de la martinique qui compte la
plus faible l'une des plus faibles
population moins de 2000 habitants et
son maire se retrouve président de
l'association des maires de martinique
bon ben voilà très bien vous entendez
que si vous êtes élu au mois de mars
prochain si vous êtes réélu maire
d'ajouts pas bouillon est ce que vous
serez aussi candidats à poursuivre cette
seconde à cette fonction en quelque
sorte pendant quelques temps de
président de l'association des maires
oui à l'association des maires ça m'a
permis effectivement 2
fréquentez pas mal de personnes d'avoir
des contacts avec pavel a pas mal de
personnes non seulement avec eux mais
avec le doute qu'aux collaborateurs mais
avec les autres causes et lui apprendre
la martinique est aussi de la métropole
parce qu'effectivement et emprisonnent
d'associer à ce duel donc n'avait jt
invité à participer à pas mal de
réunions là bas donc c'est vrai que bon
mais c'est une structure qui normalement
devait se trouver à la tête de tout ce
qu'il y ait comme comme travers eux
revendiquent a fait ou éducatif à faire
pour les collectivités je crois que
bombay peut dire que quelque part et il
nous manque quelque chose à ce niveau de
l'association des maires mais je crois
aussi que c'est qu'une jeune structure
qui a fait le maximum pour faire que ça
soit les anciens comme les nouveaux et
puis si vous êtes mère déjà pas bouillon
vous serai candidat à votre propre
succession à la tête de l'association il
ya des jeunes qui arrivent depuis
quelques années que je pense que quand
même il y assez hautain qui aurait aimé
aussi vivre ce que j'ai vécu dans ses
sculptures et je crois que c'est pas la
taille de la commune qui fait quoi que
ce soit puisque dans l'espace une vous
avez bien vu que bombay peut-être alors
vous passerez la manger parce que c'est
un tel mandat mais dites moi comment
envisagez-vous le développement d'ajouts
pas bouillon pour les six prochaines
années si vous êtes réélu alors vous
avez dit moins de 2000 habitants faut
peut-être lui donner un peu
d'attractivité tout en lui gardant son
cachet là j'en parlais tout à l'heure
alors la joue pas il faut bien se le
dise et c'est un abri là lorsque nous
sommes arrivés bambins la toiture ce
matin de partout il y avait des trous
partout je crois qu'aujourd'hui on est
un peu à l'abri de tous puisque bombe et
nous avons toutes les infrastructures
que nous avions quitté vieille saint
pons les arts innover mairie école
élémentaire écoles primaires je crois
que les bâtiments que nous avions les
vieux bâtiments que nous avions nous
avons réussi à les faire revenir à
l'ordre du jour les voies communales
malhao sites où vous avez un problème
avec des habitants il y avait un
problème d'amiante en cours mais cette
affaire-là apaisé ou pas je ne sais pas
s'il allait comme en fin de compte je
pense que le maire ne savait pas chacun
est bien
chacun a bien compris que cette
affaire-là bon ben c'est pas non plus le
meilleur seulement il ya non seulement
le meilleur qui
ok naturellement récupère ce qui s'est
passé avant quoi moi mais il ya aussi
cette population là qui vit à la cité
qui naturellement a une part de
responsabilité dans l'inventeur de ce
que nous devions faire voilà c'est à
dire les dossiers les dossiers n'étaient
pas les dossiers les dossiers entraîné
les dossiers en beaucoup trop donné
j'avais pas trop loin dit que la danse
car faire a dit maurice monte alors
c'est quoi votre proposition phare là
pour les décisions viennent les six
années qui viennent à douter président
est presque déjà clair un bon on va
terminer l'école primaire la
bibliothèque qui est quelqu'un dont les
travaux ont été arrêtés
on va terminer sa certaines voiries bon
ben on avait fait des promesses donc ces
voiries là il reste plus beaucoup à
faire fort heureusement et puis
naturellement il y a deux espaces un
espace commercial au centre bourg là où
il y avait deux vieilles bâtisses qui
ont été démolis donc effectivement il ya
sept cet espace là où nous allons faire
un aménagement commercial et un
aménagement de logements ça c'est une
première ça c'est dans le coeurs debout
le marché était déjà fait la place du 22
mai elle est faite et puis bon il nous
reste encore un espace en face de la
mairie qui a oublié toute une
infrastructure sportive avec foot hand
ball pétanque alors vu cela est fait là
dans les prochaines value je pense que
demandent les six années à venir puisque
en ce moment quand atteint actuellement
pas au don d'une somme en contact
aujourd'hui avec la spl que nous donne
un gros coup de main sur les études
d'aider des projets que nous avons je
pense que là ça il a beaucoup plus vite
et puis bon vin que financièrement nous
on a les reins suffisamment solides pour
suivre en quelques mots il semble qu'à
l'heure où on parle vous soyez le seul
candidat pour cette élection municipale
et communautaire ajoupa bouillon
ça vous dit ça vous fait bizarre c'est
peut-être un peu dommage je crois mais
que ça me fasse du bien je ne sais pas
trop ce que ça fasse du bien à la
population je ne sais pas trop non plus
ça fait ça nous fait c est tellement
moins de travail mais je pense que
bombay si je suis aujourd'hui le seul
candidat jusqu'à maintenant c'est que
bombay les gens là la population
lyonnaise a dû apprécier naturellement
aujourd'hui bombay personne n'a envie
encore essuyé la défaite supplémentaire
nous verrons cela maurice bonté merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions dans
s'en saisissent et salles municipales
c'est moi c'est la ville la joue pas
brillant